et de transporter les combattants étrangers à la frontière.
C'étaient des réseaux de mercenaires, pas d'idéologues,
qui étaient dans la coordination pour faire du profit.
Par exemple, ils faisaient payer aux combattants étrangers saoudiens
substantiellement plus qu'aux Libyens, de l'argent qui autrement
serait allé à Al Qaïda.
L'adversaire modifierait peut-être son propre réseau
s'il savait qu'ils escroquaient les aspirants jihadistes.
En janvier 2010, un tremblement de terre dévastateur a frappé Haïti,
le 3ème plus mortel de tous les temps, qui a laissé un million de gens,
10 % de la population, sans abri.
Un aspect apparemment minime de l'effort global d'aide
est devenu de plus en plus important quand on a commencé
à apporter de la nourriture et de l'eau.
Janvier et février sont les mois secs en Haïti,
pourtant des eaux stagnantes s'étaient accumulées dans beaucoup de camps.
La seule institution qui avait une connaissance détaillée
des zones inondables d'Haïti avait été détruite
dans le tremblement de terre, avec leurs dirigeants à l'intérieur.
La question était donc de savoir quels étaient les camps à risque,
combien de gens étaient dans ces camps,
quelle était la chronologie des inondations, et étant données les ressources
et l'infrastructure très limitées, comment établir les priorités de déplacement ?
Les données étaient incroyablement disparates. L'armée des États-Unis
avait une connaissance détaillée d'une seule petite section du pays.
Il y avait des données en ligne qui dataient d'une conférence
sur l'environnement de 2006, d'autres données géospatiales, rien n'était intégré.
L'objectif humain ici était d'identifier les camps à utiliser
selon l'urgence.
L'ordinateur devait intégrer une grande quantité
d'informations géospatiales, de données des médias sociaux
et des informations des organisations de secours pour répondre à cette question.
En implémentant un processus supérieur, ce qui autrement
était une tâche pour 40 personnes pendant 3 mois,
c'est devenu un travail simple pour 3 personnes en 40 heures,
tout ça à mettre au crédit de la symbiose homme-machine.
Nous voici 50 ans après la vision d'avenir de Licklider
et les données suggèrent que nous devrions être
très enthousiastes à l'idée de nous attaquer aux problèmes les plus difficiles de ce siècle,
l'homme et la machine coopérant ensemble.
Merci. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)